good morning everyone and thank you
again for joining this webinar welcome
this is a free webinar organized by our
team here at pine biotech the webinar
will cover several topics from the
upcoming biomedical data science program
and we'll be launching this program
September 16th in this webinar we will
be looking at the program details will
learn about biomedical data and see
several examples of data processing
visualization and analysis the onyx
logic programs are designed to cover
important topics and cutting-edge
technologies related to biomedical
research clinical analytics and Industry
R&D in these programs we cover topics
like genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and machine
learning for biomedical data the onyx
logic program is focused on the data
science aspect of biomedical data
analysis and deals with technical skills
and application of data science
principles to high-throughput biomedical
data you can register for the upcoming
program and attend these introductory
webinars to learn about the topics we
will cover see examples of the
activities that we will hold and ask any
questions you might have so to register
for the program you have to first fill
out the form on this link and then after
you fill out this form you will be
receiving information about how you can
register for the actual program so you
can see the landing page right here and
I'll just paste this link in chat for
everybody to take a look of course most
of you have already filled out the form
down here at the bottom but just to
explain the process itself once your
information is recorded we will be
sending out invitations to attend these
webinars and then we will also send out
more information about the program and
if you have missed any webinar we will
share that video with you
in this webinar we will start
introducing biomedical data analysis
techniques and approaches that you can
master and adopt to help you conduct
better research and learn about how data
science is changing the whole biomedical
research field from diagnosis to
treatment selection and even development
of new therapeutics specifically we will
look at high-throughput biomedical data
different types of data and different
analysis methods and we will see how you
can effectively utilize technical tools
like Excel the tion for platform and
even our to solve challenges typical to
research and industry environments we
also want to share with you information
and a preview of our upcoming course
that will cover the most important
aspects of high to put biomedical data
analysis combining reproducible
workflows with machine learning methods
and visualization approaches for various
high-throughput biomedical datasets so
this program again will start on
September 16 and these free webinars
before the program will help cover some
of the topics and show how we will
conduct the program if you have any
questions we will answer those questions
so for example somebody is asking do we
need to know any language like our
beforehand no you do not need to know
anything before of course it's
beneficial to know some molecular
biology I think it's important to kind
of have a sense of what type of
biomedical challenges there are and be
able to manipulate tables in software
like Excel but beyond that you really
don't need to know anything this is
going to start at a very low
introductory level and we will together
walk through these different methods and
applications and learn together how to
effectively do the bare minimum to
actually get some insights from data
this program is organized by a skilled
team of experts that have a diverse
perspective on the challenges and
methods that we will be covering Delco
Medan
is a data scientist and biostatistician
Mohit Mazumdar holds a PhD in
bioinformatics and has worked for
several years in the industry of
applying machine learning to big
biomedical data and my name is Ilya
broadsky I'm one of the cofounders of
Pine Fanta our company is working
closely with research and industry
partners to develop technology solutions
for big data and Onix integration so
what we will do in this course is
introduce you to some of the tools that
we have developed and some of the tools
that are commonly used both in industry
and in research but just to tell you a
little bit more about the company you
can go to this link pine biotech comm
and look at our story to learn more
about our team and you can also look at
the websites of the tower bioinformatics
Research Center which is a
bioinformatics Research Center at
University of Haifa in Israel and our
company is a technology transfer company
that came out of that Center essentially
we have access to the expertise that
they have and also to allow the
algorithms and workflows that they have
been developing there over the course of
the past 10 to 15 years with a large
group of experts working primarily in
bioinformatics so let's talk about the
program itself making sense of data so
what kind of data are we talking about
what can we do with this data and what
is the purpose of knowing how to manage
and analyze this kind of data how can we
understand that especially large
quantities of data that do not make
sense right away so here we'll talk
about two important data science
principles data visualization has a way
to communicate human intelligence and
machine learning artificial intelligence
as
no data science is already impacting
many industries for example data
visualization can be an important
technique utilized by decision-makers
that need to decide on marketing revenue
generation or financial market trends to
make a decision about return on
investment are alive from advertising
one can simply look at the number of
impressions from ads and pick the ads
consistently delivering the information
to the target audience so what you see
is a heat map and the darker the square
the more impressions and you can see
this across the whole week and how you
can compare our why well if you're
paying for impressions obviously the
darker ad set the more effective it is
so as a decision maker if I need to
maximize revenue I'm going to pick just
based on the visual representation of
data this ad set also in financial
markets if we have good visualization of
financial information that we can gain
from markets if this information is
accurate and up-to-date we can easily
compare different currencies and we can
select which currency produces long term
value a different visualization this is
a bar plot and we can see that the scale
is very different here we were talking
about a week scale here we're talking a
whole year and we can use simple
elements like a threshold it's not very
visible here but there's a red line and
that is a threshold that can demonstrate
to me what has a long-term change and
what has a short-term change so as a
financial decision maker I can make
decisions about capital gains utilizing
effective visualization
so this kind of visualization ultimately
helps us deal with large quantities of
data and make better decisions
what about biomedical data visualization
well a simple biomedical data source is
the heart rate so here we can see a
cardiogram and in this cardiogram we can
easily spot a trend but we also can spot
abnormalities so something that stands
out to us right away but as we extend
this data set now this information is
more difficult to spot and you can
imagine if we continuously have this
heart rate without constantly looking at
the cardiogram it is very difficult to
spot these kinds of abnormalities so how
can we translate this type of data into
data that is more informative one way to
do this is to look at a different scale
transform this data into a completely
different scale to make the trends
associated with information that we can
intuitively understand so here you can
see first of all a scale that does not
include the individual heart rate the
heart heartbeat but actually shows us
something that happened over several
hours as we look at this different scale
we can start associating this
information with a story so this is
actually heart rate during marriage
proposal and now we can see this whole
story unfold here somebody is walking in
Coliseum buying ice cream enjoying ice
cream walking forwards started proposing
silently started proposing using words
finally getting this exciting answer yes
peak of happiness and then reverting to
normal heart rate that the person had
before the marriage proposal this
demonstrates that some biomedical data
can be almost instantly informative when
it is appropriately visual
alized selecting the right criteria for
visualization and adding other
information into the visualization that
we have produces the result that we are
interested in so why are these data
science techniques important in the
biomedical field well first of all a lot
of the biomedical field is turning
towards data-driven insight instead of
deep knowledge of every single aspect of
biomedical research that were engaged in
we are flooded with information that
comes in raw data format and to produce
insight from that raw data you have to
utilize data science principles another
big aspect of it is reproducibility we
cannot just rely on stochastic events or
technical variation and knowing how to
adjust for those elements we can make
our experiments our data and our
analysis results more reproducible it's
also easier to combine context and make
it more easy to compare between
different conditions different
situations and different data types we
also have to consider rapid prototyping
many times we will get a lot of raw data
from different sources and quickly have
to estimate what we are looking for what
kind of trends exist in the data
what kind of comparisons to make and
ultimately how do we communicate this
information to our peers collaborators
and even buyers in the sense people that
make decisions about our research people
making decisions about hiring us people
making decisions about the data that
they would like to generate to confirm
or prove a hypothesis that we have
generated to do that a lot of times we
can simplify the process between raw
data and informative visualization that
somebody else can interpret by making
programmable visual
and we'll talk about that in this
program as well
now let's talk about high throughput
experiments what we've seen until now
are examples of data that is already
somewhat intuitive we can visualize it
and connect it to a phenotype and that
makes sense but with high throughput
experiments there are new challenges and
new opportunities so to jump into that
let's talk a little bit about the
history of genomic data so as you all
know in the 1950s DNA structure was
discovered and quickly after that a lot
of excitement around the human genome
which was assembled between 90s and 2003
and ultimately gave rise to new type of
information this genomic information
transformed the NIH and mainly different
companies popped up that utilized this
data for a variety of different
biomedical challenges but with the
coming of Illumina sequencing the
shotgun sequencing we saw a dramatic
drop in the cost of sequencing of
next-generation sequencing and therefore
in 2015 we already had the 1,000 genomes
project
published and in 2018 we're now talking
about a single human genome we're
talking about hundreds of thousands of
human genomes with this amount of
information the challenge is now
different the challenge is to link the
disease symptoms the phenotypes the
clinical phenotypes the clinical data
with a variety of onok data or multi
Olmec data because today we are seeing
more and more projects that are
collecting data from different levels of
omics
helping us we reclassified different
diseases understand better the clinical
symptoms that we ultimately are looking
for so this medical data is the type of
information that we gather from clinical
tests diagnostic labs and we want to
link that data with this molecular level
of detail genomics
proteomics transcriptomics epigenomics
microbiome
etc so let's take a look at an example
here's an example a publication that we
see used data from cell lines where they
generated multiple levels of onyx
genomic data transcriptomic data
epigenomic data and combine that with
two types of phenotypes one is a
clinical subtype of these different
breast cancer cell lines or in this case
actually it's a pan-cancer data set and
GI 50 growth inhibition of these cells
in response to different treatments
typical to chemotherapy targeted therapy
and other cancer drugs the result was
using machine learning so you can see
here random forests and support vector
machines to predict based on molecular
class predict the response to a
treatment now this is prototyping where
we are essentially trying to prove the
idea that we can use multiple levels of
molecular data to accurately predict a
personalized treatment selection of
drugs for patients for cancer patients
let's take a look at some aspects of
this project using some hands-on
practical examples so first part is
processing this data these are huge
datasets we're talking about hundreds of
gigabytes of data that all come in fast
queue files files that contain multiple
short reads from each sample and the
first challenge like you will find in
many of these biomedical situations is
to process the data prepare this data
for analysis in this program we will
look at how we can easily process data
like this understanding
every step and learning how to create
pipelines bioinformatics pipelines that
take the raw data and produce tables or
matrices that we will then use for
visualization and for analysis so these
are the links you can take a look the
link for the platform is server dot T -
file info and you will see there these
areas of analysis in these areas of
analysis we will focus on the
transcriptomics section the
transcriptomics section will help us
process next-generation sequencing data
and produce quantified levels of gene
expression let's take a look so we will
go to server dot T - bio info and if you
go there you will see something like
this ok
hovering over in each section you can
learn about each one of these sections
and essentially you will see a
consistent interface in each one of
these sections so here we have our nice
eke data here we have single cell
transcriptome we have chip seek data
genomic data a mutation variant data and
other types of analyses that you can
perform once you get an account and a
part of this program will provide you
with an account where you can run your
own analyses and also learn about these
different sections once you have your
account you will be able to log in and
utilize the demo section just to
understand what steps are included in
processing this kind of data so let's
take a look here I'm in the demo section
we won't go into the type of inputs and
how to set this pipeline up but just to
demonstrate some of these steps as we
start you already know the main steps
that are included in processing these
large data set you have to pre-process
the data where we remove additional
trimming of adapters removing PCR
duplicates mapping on the genome and
then quantification of Express
and levels as you can see now only the
next steps that are appropriate for my
data are going to light up so I can
start with pre-processing shrim ematic
removes the adapters PCR clean helps
eliminate the PCR amplification then I
will actually map my reads on the
transcriptome so you can see here that
the reads will be aligned to exons of
genes and then I will create a table of
expression a table that will look like
this it will have genes listed right
here and samples listed as columns let's
click on end and each step of this
pipeline is much more in-depth explained
over here you can click on this link
let's not go there right now so you can
learn about each one of those steps much
more in detail click OK and we have
expression data so a table of expression
you can just click and download it right
here and let's take a look at what's
inside what we have inside as we saw is
a matrix a matrix means that it has rows
and columns and inside it has continuous
data so this is called gene expression
let's look at how many genes we have we
have just close to 7,000 genes so let me
go back to the presentation and continue
from here so as you saw we use this
platform and created a bioinformatics
pipeline that helped us transform the
raw reads into a table so we created
this pipeline we did pre-processing we
did alignment to the reference genome
and then quanta
vacation and as a result we got this
table of expression the table of
expression shows us how between
different subtypes of breast cancer
different genes are expressed now how
can we deal with this data we have
twenty to sixty thousand genes per
sample in that case we saw already a
filtered table of seven thousand genes
but originally you would be looking at
thousands and thousands of genes per
sample but also we have tens to hundreds
of samples the era when we looked at two
or three samples per condition is over
today almost any project is going to
have multiples of tens for each
condition and we have a lot of this data
available on public domain data sets so
for example NCBI as correctly mentioned
in the chat or you even generate this
data yourself and there are other
repositories and we will cover some of
those repositories and project examples
but the problem is that there are very
complex relationships here between each
sample and between each gene just by
looking at the table it's non-trivial
how to explain this type of information
how do you interpret it what does it
mean in about these different cancer
types so let's take a look at how we can
leverage data exploration and
visualization for this table to use
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning techniques and helps help us
extract some meaning from this table so
essentially what we will try to do is
take a look at the samples in this
representation you can see a scatterplot
of different subtypes of cancer and here
we can easily spot a trend right we can
see that there is a group right here and
another group right here so at least two
groups that is already very important
insight so let us take a look at how we
can perform such an analysis quickly and
then we will dig into the
analysis and understand a little bit
better how we can recreate the analysis
ourselves so let's go back to areas of
analysis and we'll start with
unsupervised analysis now we will upload
that same dataset that we just looked at
press him continue and we will use pca
principal component analysis using an R
script so then we will look at the
script itself understand how it works
and modify some things to make an even
better representation of our data so
we'll take this PCA a our library we
will produce a scatter plot and we have
several inputs here that we can take a
look at let's click on end and I will
give this a name PCA our library cell
lines breast cancer 7,000 genes and
let's run this pipeline now the pipeline
is very simple we just load in the data
we launch an R script and then we
produce the result now we will look at
the result and we will see what would
this result actually look like and how
do we manipulate this result further so
let's take a look at a pipeline I just
finished before this session and here we
have a PDF file that shows us a visual
result so let's take a look ok so now we
transformed our whole data of 7,000
genes and 53 samples that we took we
will see that there are two major groups
right here's one and we can see down
here this is luminal so luminal subtype
and then here we have the other subtypes
but there's clearly some other groups as
well but maybe we cannot easily
English between them the other thing
that this pipeline provides us is a
downloadable zip file with an R script
so let us take a look at this R script
and see what does it actually contain so
here I am in our studio we will go
through some of the details about our
studio and how to set it up how to make
sure that you have the most up-to-date
version and how you can install all the
libraries needed for this analysis but
let us look at two simple sections of
the script loading the data you can see
that I'm loading cell lines expression
data marked and then you can Z sorry you
can see that I am loading the data and
transforming it into a matrix that now I
can take information from and then make
the visualization so now you can see
drawing PCA plot and you can see some of
the settings so let us look at how does
this actually work we will run the
script and let's change this okay let's
just change it to PCA so we will produce
an image PCA dot PNG let's run this
again and now after we have created this
simple image you can see it appears
right here we can click on that okay and
this is what we see right so we've
changed some things instead of looking
at different colors we have here the
names of the sample subtypes and we have
these arrows right these are called
loadings and you can see that each
loading has a name it has the name of a
gene let's take and make it a little bit
more interesting something like this so
first of all we will change the file so
we take a file that contains the labels
also not just the expression data and
also here
you will see how some of this
functionality will start working
differently just by loading a different
type sorry let's call this PC a1 okay
let's run this again now a very simple
change
we just took a data set that contains a
little bit more information and let's
look at the result
okay now the result is much more
interesting the result is much more
interesting because now the groups are
also colored right so now we can see the
color of the group which cell subtype
breast cancer subtypes this is and also
you can see the groups of other subtypes
are circled so it's easier to
differentiate and indeed there is some
difference between these groups as well
how do I know well PCA shows us variance
it shows us variance and you can see
that PC one represents 18 percent of the
variance and PC to 12 percent of the
variance so this represents about 20
percent of the variance that fact that
they are in different X location on this
x-axis means that there is some
separation now there's a lot more that
we can do with this data let's quickly
look and how we can transform and select
certain genes out of this whole data set
and make an even more clear separation
between these groups so let us go and we
will now take a look at a different
table and I have to set this as my
working directory and now I have to
change cell lines 15 genes marked okay
and let let's keep this PCA 1 we will
run the file and you can see PCA 1 okay
now we have a much better representation
of these different groups so you can see
how
of a sudden they separate and the
information that we have about loadings
is much more clearly interpretable in
fact what we can now see the direction
of this arrow corresponds to the
direction of variants so we can see and
by the way the question here is use of
our studio will be explained in this
course yes just as I'm demonstrating
here we'll do a lot of exercises like
this this is just one example where we
will look at our studio packages that
can help us produce meaningful
visualizations and improve upon the
visualizations the standard
visualizations that you get out of this
out of this session okay so now you
could see how we took a large data set
seven thousand genes fifty three cell
lines we produce the simple
visualization and we saw some major
trend separation in two sample groups
after that we selected some specific
genes okay so we saw essentially how how
this type of information can be used to
analyze high-throughput data now the
high throughput data that we looked at
we just took dimensionality reduction
you can see here a good representation
of pca it's essentially like twisting my
whole data set until i get a clear
enough picture that helps me separate
between the samples now we will also
look at these other methods that we have
here clustering methods as well as
supervised classification methods that
fall under the category of machine
learning so in this course what we will
do is we will start by understanding the
projects the projects range from cancer
to resistance microbial resistance to
antibiotics in tuberculosis to other
types of projects with a clear
biomedical challenge
we will then learn the logic of going
from raw data to data that we can look
at and we can analyze and we can
visualize and then we will go into the
technical detail we will take a look at
our studio we will take a look at other
types of libraries not just the one that
we saw today and we will learn how to
understand and how to modify the scripts
so ultimately you will be able to
leverage the Big Data environment that
we have to process rapidly process Big
Data then you will be able to download
that data download those methods and
modify them on your computer so
improving those results and making sure
that we go from something that is
somewhat interesting which is called
data mining we start spotting some
trends and then ultimately to
classification and feature selection
which is the use of machine learning to
find a gene set in this case that could
be used as a predictive classifier and
ultimately we will understand how it
works the internal working of this
method what principles are used to
select those genes and how do we
correlate between what we see in this
kind of a visual representation with
what it actually means so here you can
see this is a gene right we talked about
loadings a little bit so this is a gene
and this gene if you just thought its
expression you can see right here that
the expression level corresponds with
what we see in this picture because this
line the direction of this line is
longest that separates between this and
the rest right and here you can see that
this is high expression and this is
luminal data so this all is luminal and
these are all the rest of them and we'll
also see how this type of information
can help us prepare classification of
the whole data set so that we can better
understand what's going on
and create reproducible models so this
is again just an example but I want to
cover some other things that we will
look at during this program so as I
mentioned we will take a look at
biomechanical challenges the whole
biomedical field is now being both
challenged and it's presented with an
opportunity to leverage these large and
very precise molecular datasets to
navigate this whole area of disease
therapeutic intervention into the
disease early detection of disease and
understanding of targets how do these
molecular mechanisms work how are they
altered and how they can be adjusted by
external external impact but we will
look at it specifically from the data
side so we are going to look at how we
can leverage tools and data science
principles to adapt to this new kind of
dimension where so much data and it's so
detailed and we have to extract
meaningful insights then we will look at
data processing so here you can see this
is data processing a series of lessons
where we can take a look at the
properties of data the statistical
properties of data the data the data
distribution variants various technical
things that impact the different types
of data that we have different types of
data continuous categorical and others
and we will look at how to understand
the data from a statistical perspective
to make decisions in the way we set up
our next steps for example the principal
component analysis that we just did was
done on data that was transformed to log
normal distribution because specifically
gene expression does not follow normal
distribution
out of the box when we just process so
therefore we need to do log
transformation and prepare the data by
also leveraging tools like quantile
normalization so we'll talk about why
and how and practically see examples of
where these types of data processing and
data cleaning and data preparation
techniques are going to be very powerful
in terms of the types of outcomes and
the types of insights that you can get
out of them then we will take a look at
data mining once we have a lot of this
data once we have so much access on NCBI
on TCGA on all of these big data
repositories where we have thousands of
samples thousands of genomes how can we
mine this data essentially learning from
the data itself understanding what can
this data tell us once we understand
what the data can tell us now we can
come up with a very specific question
and that question a lot of times can be
transformed into a model and so then the
last part we will talk about
classification we'll talk about using
machine learning methods preparing
different types of methods making sure
that these methods produce reproducible
results and we will look at how these
machine learning models could be trained
to give us prediction about new types of
data and how we can test and validate
that that is actually true now I see a
lot of you are having questions about
what types of data will we deal with so
essentially we will deal with data
science principles which dataset you
will apply those principles to is up to
you we will teach you about preparing
the data any type of data you can take
raw data and process it but ultimately
all of these methods are going to work
with tables and those tables could be
tables of expression tables of amount of
mutations in a gene sequence they could
be copying
number variation they could be number of
epigenetic peaks in gypsy or methylation
of DNA so you can look at many different
data types but also will touch on non
comics in the standard word meaning of
that word we will look at data that is
more clinical for example how can we
link expression of genes with age or
with a risk factor or for example ethnic
background right so we'll look at a
variety of data types that we will try
to understand by looking at these
visualizations and correlations and also
learning about the underlying statistics
of these methods how do we understand
this
looking at p-values looking and
distribution look at variants looking at
all of these different aspects to really
know how to apply these methods not out
of the box not just as they come but
with understanding so this data set this
program will start on September 16th and
we call it biomedical data simplified
because what we will try to do is we
will try to use all of these are mixed
data data sets high throughput data big
data and applied data science principles
how to process the data and prepare it
for analysis how to use machine learning
to explore the data train models and how
to leverage visualization and make the
data insights communicate able but also
insightful to ourselves
the omits logic program just to
summarize will cover the following
topics methods for high-throughput data
processing analysis and visualization
applying these methods to clinical
research and pharmaceutical projects and
here we will also talk about what kinds
of challenges are cutting-edge are most
important if you're looking to leverage
this program to make your resume stand
out what kind of a project do you want
to add to your resume if you're looking
to be hired by a pharmaceutical
or by a clinical research organization
if you're a student how can you leverage
data science to make a bigger impact on
your field in the domain of research
whether it be infectious diseases
neuroscience oncology biotechnology etc
if you are a researcher yourself we'll
talk about different types of research
practices that will make your data
analysis more reproducible that will
help you incorporate more variety and
more data into your research so that you
gain some preliminary research results
that you can apply for grants and you
can start collaborations again we are
focused on making sure that these skills
are going to be useful for you whatever
domain you are in and we are going to
make sure that those that are consistent
and can go through all of these sections
will benefit from very practical skills
and finally we will help you understand
the biomedical research and read
publications critically a lot of
publications are coming out that use
machine learning that use these
visualization techniques it's not always
clear why they chose one method over the
other or why they decided to show their
results in this way or another way so we
will go through some of these examples
and decipher how exactly these decisions
are made and what makes an impactful
representation and what is not an
impactful representation and finally you
will obtain a certificate of completion
of this course so all of you will follow
a specific schedule that we'll go over
right now that you can by attending all
of the sessions and completing all of
the assignments in the sessions will
give you a way to get a certificate of
completion so what is the schedule as we
said we will start on September 16 and
that whole week 16th to the 20th will be
an introduction we'll talk about high
throughput data experiments what are the
challenges what
the opportunities what are some of these
onyx technologies genomics
transcriptomics and some of the other
ones how do we apply this to the domain
of precision medicine molecular data or
drug discovery so we'll talk about these
topics and we will meet a couple of
times during this week and also
introduce you to some of the resources
where you can learn on your own and
understand these things in more detail
based on where your interests lies then
we will talk about exploratory data
analysis so September 24th to October
4th we'll talk about descriptive
statistics data preparation probability
correlation and Association common data
visualization techniques in Excel and
are then between October 10th and 18th
sorry 7th and late teens we will talk
about data mining how do we leverage
these methods of dimensionality
reduction like principal component
analysis how do we understand features
and objects how do we use filtering
normalization and log transformation
what are the types of clustering methods
that we will typically apply why do we
use hierarchical clustering or k-means
or other dimension based clustering how
do we understand when to use what and
what problems are going to be solved and
then between October 21st and the 31st
so by the end of October we will look at
classification discriminant analysis
including stepwise Lda Lda and those
types of discriminant analysis decision
trees and random forests what is random
forest how can we modify random for us
to produce more reliable results and
then we'll talk about efficiency how can
we leverage support vector machines and
classification like that so this program
again is a about two months long month
and a half maybe closer to two months we
will meet at least twice a week we our
team will be available to interact with
you one-on-one and help you address
specific challenges you will find a lot
of
resources that we will provide as a part
of our educational ecosystem and also
it's a way to get new connections in the
industry and in research if you're a
researcher if you're a student if you're
working in industry we will sorry we
will make sure that you are familiar
with our team with our network and also
between each other we will facilitate
collaborative projects so if you find an
opportunity to work together we will
help you work together and make the most
out of this time a question will this
course cover some aspects already
covered in precision ecology so for
those of you that are already familiar
with our other rmx logic programs we run
six different comix logic programs
throughout the year including
introduction to t bio info the platform
the environment the bioinformatics
challenges and opportunities we run a
program on genomics on transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and this is a
program focused on data science only in
this program we will talk about more
technical level how do you incorporate
the bio statistical principles and the
machine learning algorithms how do you
code in our how do you set up the our
environment so none of those things are
actually covered in most of the other
programs most of the other programs are
focused on data types and data
processing and inference okay so let's
turn to some of the questions the
questions are what is the registration
fee how do we register what are we going
to cover etc so again we will be sending
out more emails following this webinar
we will hold another webinar also on
September 10th and we will be reaching
out to you about registration so the
registration is $200 for the whole
program there are discounts available
for students and researchers that are
going to leverage the things that we
learn in this course and we will guide
you through those details
based on your background and based on
the submission of the form that you are
going to be submitting on the on the
landing page just briefly if you see an
email with biomedical data simplified or
hands-on biomedical data science that is
an email from us if you want to reach
out to us you can contact us and we will
be happy to either schedule a call one
on one call we have a whole team here on
chat but also in our team in India and
in the US you can easily reach us and we
would love to talk to you and understand
if you have any questions or if you need
any assistance with any part of this so
I again want to urge you to stay in
touch with us and look out for some of
these coming emails and join us again
September 10th September 10th we will
have another webinar and we will talk a
little bit more in depth about some of
the project examples that we will cover
based on the discussion today and based
on how we will be conducting the program